foreign
[Music]
and I'm Zach and we're going to show you
10 ways of using machine learning with
Google Cloud
we're going to cover beginner
intermediate and advanced ways of doing
machine learning
beginner is perfect for those brand new
to machine learning and who want to use
it without the expertise
an intermediate is for those that have
some knowledge of machine learning but
may want to customize their models
Advanced is for the ml engineer who
wants to take their skills or knowledge
to the next level with full
customizability and at the Enterprise
grade scale
and we're going to give you links for
each of these tools where you can learn
more
let's get started
hey Zach I'm trying to build a prototype
to classify images specifically for
identifying flower species based on some
photos I have
I don't have a lot of photos yet but I
really just want the fastest way to get
a quick proof of concept out the door
what could I use
that sounds like a perfect use case for
teachable machine
it's a browser-based tool that lets you
build image or audio classifiers in just
a couple of minutes
and what's really great about it is that
you can capture training data directly
from your webcam or microphone right
away
you can see here we're uploading our
flower images and training a brand new
model right in the browser
and once the model is trained we can
make predictions right in the browser to
test it out
also by the end of this we'll have a
full machine learning model that we can
export
and this model is a tensorflow lite
model which means we can deploy it
anywhere like mobile web or even in the
cloud
so that's teachable machine the perfect
tool for your prototypes
all right Zach I'm trying to build an
Enterprise grade image classification
model but I don't really have the
expertise and my model needs to be
really accurate and scale well
I'm not a data scientist or ml engineer
but I already have a label data set
ready to go what can I use
ah now that sounds like a perfect use
case for automl in vertex AI
it's a machine learning tool for
developers on Google Cloud that allows
you to train custom Enterprise grade
models based on your own data
you can use it to build models to
predict on your images video text or
even tabular data
because it's part of vertex AI you can
easily deploy your models for
large-scale batch and real-time
predictions
hey Mr Zack I'm a developer and I have
an app where I want to add some
ml-powered capabilities without needing
to build or deploy any models myself
specific tasks like image labeling
sentiment analysis or text
classification what can I use that just
works out of the box
ah excellent question
I think some of the pre-trained ml apis
would be perfect
these are powerful pre-trained models
that allow you to embed machine learning
capabilities directly into your
applications with just a single API call
you can see here how there are great
common tasks like sentiment analysis and
text object and person detection in
video
and even some really cool things like
Landmark detection in photos
and there's loads of other features that
I haven't even mentioned so definitely
check out the ml apis in vertex AI
hey Zach I want to generate images and
text where can I begin
now that sounds like a perfect use case
for generative AI Studio
it is a managed environment in vertex AI
that makes it easy to deploy interact
with and tune generative models to
production
it's got a simple interface for prompt
design tuning and deployment for
developers to get started building with
generative AI
let's walk through an example
let's say I have some blog content
around healthy granola bars and I want
to generate a multimedia marketing
campaign around this
using just the blog content I can write
a prompt and generative AI studio will
generate a Blog title headline and
Instagram caption with hashtags for a
marketing campaign
and there you have a Blog headline a
blog post and an Instagram content for
our campaign
no ml expertise required and you can
also view the API code to use generative
AI Studio programmatically
we can also use vertex's generative
Vision AI capabilities
with our image generation model I can
use the simple text prompts to generate
images that go along with my marketing
campaign
you can see here a prompt being used to
generate multiple images of a granola
bar on a kitchen table and that we can
then use these images in our marketing
campaign
and that's just one example of how you
can use generative AI Studio
but note you can also tune the
foundation model as well
hey Polo
I'm looking for a single place where I
can search discover and use models that
might be available to me on Google Cloud
where can I go for this
ah for that use case you might really
like vertex AI model Garden it provides
a single environment to search discover
and interact with curated models both
from Google and open source
from model Garden you can kick off a
variety of workflows including using the
model directly as an API tuning the
model in generative AI Studio or
deploying the model directly to a data
science notebook in vertex AI
we've also just launched four new apis
that will be available in the model
Garden
we've announced our code generation and
completion models which can help with
software development
we've also announced an image generation
model which includes the ability to edit
and iterate over images you've generated
we've also announced our Universal
speech model which is the next
generation of speech to text
and then we've also announced an
embeddings model which lets you extract
embeddings from unstructured data hey
Polo
I wish I had a way to tune my models to
understand my preferences in the way
that they respond to me
what should I do
well I heard that gcp is coming out with
a new capability called reinforcement
learning from Human feedback or rlhf for
short
with rlhf you can tune your models to
learn directly from positive or negative
feedback and use that to optimize the
performance of your models be on the
lookout for more news about this
exciting capability later this year hey
Polo
I've already got a lot of data in
bigquery and ideally I'd like to use
this data to train my own machine
learning models but I'm not quite sure
where to begin
aha well that sounds like a perfect use
case for bigquery ML
using just SQL you can train evaluate
make predictions all within bigquery
without needing to move your data out of
your data warehouse
so in this example you can create a
classification model in SQL with a
create model statement then make
predictions using an ml.predict query
you can even use bigquery ml directly on
your unstructured data via an exciting
new capability called bigquery ml
inference engine
so say you have unstructured data like
image files stored in Google Cloud
Storage but your primary workflow is all
through bigquery so now using bigquery
ml inference engine you can run
inference directly on data stored in
cloud storage through bigquery your
models could be imported tensorflow
models xgboost models Onyx models or
even a custom vertex AI endpoint that
you have deployed and if you don't have
a model at hand you can use the
pre-trained ml apis like the vision
natural language and translate apis
check out the bigquery ml link for more
information
I want to get my hands dirty and play
around with machine learning libraries
in Python
how do I get started as quick as
possible
as quick as possible that sounds like a
perfect use case for collab in seconds
you can create a collab notebook and
start using python directly in the
browser you can import or install your
favorite libraries and you can even load
notebooks or code that you found online
or check out some of the sample
notebooks you can also use collab with
Google cloud like reading data from
bigquery so check out collab in the link
below alright Polo
I've played around with collab and I'm
loving the notebook environment
but I'm an Enterprise developer and now
I want to think about production
workloads and I also want to think about
Integrations with the rest of Google
Cloud
what can I do
that's a great question and it sounds
like you might get a kick out of vertex
AI workbench you can create and
customize Jupiter lab instances on
Google Cloud
so here you can see some instances with
just Python and others with tensorflow
or Pi torch pre-installed with gpus
attached and as you open an instance
it's the familiar Jupiter notebook
interface
you can create new instances and
customize things like the size of your
machine and location and permissions and
it's got great Integrations with the
rest of Google Cloud because it's part
of Google Cloud
I'm a machine or an engineer and I need
an Enterprise grade way to train my
custom models at scale what can I use
well Zach might I say that that is a
perfect use case for vertex AI custom
Training you can bring your ml code and
run it in a cloud with vertex AI you can
keep track of your model experiments use
automated hyper parameter tuning and
leverage mlops capabilities of vertex AI
like orchestrating your model training
and deployment workflows with vertex AI
Pipelines
so imagine that I have a model that I've
been training in a notebook environment
for experimentation
and maybe once I'm closer to production
or if I have a really heavy training
workloads then I might just train
directly using vertex AI custom Training
so I containerize my code then submit it
to vertex AI custom Training to run it
for me in a managed and repeatable way
so find out more about vertex AI custom
Training in the link on the screen
hey Zach I'm an Enterprise developer and
I want to build a fast AI powered search
Based on unstructured data using
embeddings what can I use
ah embeddings that sounds like a perfect
use case for vertex AI matching engine
it's our highly optimized Vector
database that stores and does fast
lookups of embeddings
but what does this mean
well in this example we have two million
random images and we want to search for
the images that look the most similar to
this yellow car
so matching engine will do an extremely
fast lookup by finding the nearest
embeddings to the embedding of this
yellow car and then it's going to return
the results in milliseconds
because it's embeddings we can use a
variety of data types like text images
video audio or anything else that you
can convert into embeddings
vertex AI matching engine even supports
real-time updates so that you can make
new data immediately searchable without
needing to re-index the entire database
awesome so that was the final item on
our list of 10 ways of doing machine
learning with Google Cloud
check out the links to learn more about
each of the 10 ways
thank you so much for watching and enjoy
the rest of Google I O
[Music]